mit's Japanese program is divided into two sections, especially at the 1st and 2nd grade levels
. One is the grounder session and the other is the
beer session. The
grammar session is basically that.
Is it a new Drew item? Introducing
patterns Then, a drill session is a student practicing the pattern learned in the
grammar in the class.The grammar session is mostly done in English.  The drill session is
a very interactive session that is done only in Japanese from the light bulb in the first grade. To
prepare for gram intake, the students
have read the explanation of the grammar properly in the textbook.
There are about 40 to 50 new words in each lesson, so
I come to live after studying
it, and then drill sessions. Mit offers many of its
interactive
um x sizes online.
Well, I'm a student who is practicing the x site online and going to a drill session
. It's from the day of 1 year old. 8 It's such a drew session only in Japanese,
but Japan  It's still very difficult for teachers to do it only in words, but
what we often do is to do it now to make a stool version, so many visuals and, of
course, slides and various
other teaching materials.  We are creating an environment where students can learn a language in that context as much as possible by bringing it into the classroom
.